>>> WE HAVE AN IMPORTANT STORY
TO TELL YOU ABOUT.
BUT A WARNING, THIS NEXT REPORT
IS DISTURBING.
IF YOU HAVE YOUNG CHILDREN IN
THE ROOM, YOU MIGHT ASK THEM TO
LEAVE.
CNN HAS OBTAINED A NEVER BEFORE
SEEN VIDEO FROM THE SHOOTING IN
UVALDE.
WHAT YOU'RE ABOUT TO HEAR IS THE
VOICE OF A 10-YEAR-OLD GIRL
NAMED CHLOE TORRES TRAPPED AT
ROBB ELEMENTARY SCHOOL WITH A
GUNMAN WHO HAD ALREADY KILLED
FRIENDS AND A DISPATCHER
SPEAKING TO THE TEACHER.
FOLLOWING THAT, YOU WILL SEE
VIDEO OF LAW ENFORCEMENT
AUTHORITIES AT THE SCHOOL
DISCUSSING THE INFORMATION THAT
CHLOE, WHO SURVIVED THE ATTACK,
GAVE THE DISPATCHER.
CNN OBTAINED THESE CALLS FROM A
SOURCE AND IS USING EXCERPTS
WITH APPROVAL FROM CHLOE'S
PARENTS.
CNN HAS INFORMED FAMILIES IN THE
MASSACRE THAT THIS STORY WAS
COMING.
>> WE DO HAVE A CHILD ON THE
LINE.
>> THIS WAS THE MOMENT
EVERYTHING AT THE SEASON IN
UVALDE SHOULD HAVE CHANGED.
AT 12:10 P.M. ON MAY 24th,
FOURTH GRADER CHLOE TORRES WHO
SURVIVED THE SHOOTING WAS INSIDE
ROOM 112 AT ROBB ELEMENTARY AND
SPOKE TO RAIN IN 11.
POLICE A FEW FEET AWAY IN THE
HALLWAY WERE MINUTES AWAY, TOLD
THE WORST-CASE SCENARIO WAS
UNFOLDING.
CHLOE, WITH HER CLASSMATES AND
TEACHERS, TRAPPED WITH AN ACTIVE
SHOOTER.
IT IS THE PHONE CALL THAT SHOULD
HAVE MADE THE DIFFERENCE.
INSTEAD, IT WOULD BE ANOTHER 40
MINUTES UNTIL POLICE FINALLY
ENTERED THE ROOM AND KILLED THE
GUNMAN.
CNN HAS OBTAINED THE CALL NEVER
MADE PUBLIC UNTIL NOW.
A WARNING TO OUR VIEWERS, IT IS
PAINFUL TO HEAR.
>> WE'RE CHOOSING TO PLAY
PORTIONS OF THE AUDIO WITH THE
APPROVAL OF CHLOE'S PARENTS.
BECAUSE IT IS CRUCIAL TO
UNDERSTANDING THE FULL SCOPE OF
THE LAW ENFORCEMENT FAILURE THAT
DAY.
>> SCHOOL SHOOTING.
>> YOU CAN HEAR INJURED PEOPLE
IN THE ROOM CRYING OUT IN PAIN.
THE DISPATCHER ASKS CHLOE TO
TELL HER CLASSMATES TO STAY
QUIET.
SHE DOES HER BEST.
LESS THAN TWO MINUTES INTO THE
CALL AT 12:12 P.M., THE UVALDE
DISPATCHER SENDS AN URGENT
MESSAGE TO POLICE AT THE SCENE.
>> HE IS ARRIVING.
HE IS IN THE ROOM FULL OF
VICTIMS.
FULL OF VICTIMS.
>> IF ACTIVE SHOOTER PROTOCOL
HAD BEEN FOLLOWED, THIS DISPATCH
SHOULD HAVE TRIGGERED POLICE TO
SPRING INTO ACTION AND BREACH
THE CLASSROOM.
INSTEAD, 38 MINUTES WERE ALLOWED
TO GO BY AS MORE OFFICERS ARRIVE
ON SCENE WITH MORE EQUIPMENT
UNTIL SOMETHING IS DONE.
NEARLY 400 OFFICERS RESPONDED IN
UVALDE.
CHLOE WANTED TO KNOW WHERE THEY
WERE.
>> THEY'RE INSIDE THE BUILDING.
STAY QUIET.
>> ON THE OTHER SIDE OF THE
DOOR, THE LAW ENFORCEMENT
RESPONSE WAS DISORGANIZED AND
CHAOTIC.
OFFICIAL REPORTS DETAIL THE
CATASTROPHIC MISTAKE THAT WAS
MADE.
POLICE ON SCENE THOUGHT THE
SHOOTER WAS A BARRICADED SUBJECT
AND NOT AN ACTIVE SHOOTER.
CHLOE' CALL MAKES IT CLEAR.
AN ACTIVE SHOOTER SITUATION IS
UNFOLDING.
BODY CAMERA FOOTAGE FROM LOCAL
AND STATE POLICE DEPARTMENTS
OBTAINED BY CNN SHOWS THE
OFFICERS ON SCENE KNEW ABOUT THE
PHONE CALL AND THAT THERE WERE
CHILDREN INSIDE THE ROOM HURT
AND IN DESPERATE NEED OF MEDICAL
ATTENTION.
>> THIS IS BUILDING FOUR?
>> ANYBODY HURT?
>> NO, SIR.
>> HERE?
>> HE'S IN HERE.
>> YEP.
>> THE LAST CONTACT WE HAD WAS
ONE OF OUR SCHOOL OFFICERS.
HIS WIFE IS A TEACHER.
>> THIS IS THE FIRST TIME I'VE
SEEN THIS.
THIS IS UNBELIEVABLE -- NOT
UNBELIEVABLE.
IT IS COMPLETELY BELIEVABLE
GIVEN THE LIES AND THE COVER-UPS
THAT HAVE BEEN GOING ON FOR SO
LONG FROM THESE PEOPLE.
BUT I MEAN, IT'S OUTRAGEOUS.
>> IT WAS SUCH A HARD DECISION
TO MAKE WHETHER OR NOT TO AIR
THIS, ANDERSON.
AND OUR TEAM, WE WERE SORT OF IN
A PLACE, HOW DO WE TELL THIS
STORY ABOUT HOW HORRIFIC IT
REALLY WAS INSIDE THE CLASSROOM?
>> THEY KNEW THERE WAS A LITTLE
GIRL TALKING TO OTHER KIDS WHO
WERE ALIVE TELLING THEM THE
TEACHERS WERE WOUNDED, BLEEDING,
ASKING FOR HELP, AND THE LITTLE
GIRL PASSING ON, THEY'RE IN THE
SCHOOL.
AS IF SHE BELIEVES THEY'RE GOING
TO COME IN.
BECAUSE OF COURSE THEY SHOULD
COME IN.
>> OVER A DOZEN TIME SHE'S
ASKING FOR HELP.
WHERE ARE THEY?
SHE'S WITH HER FRIEND.
THEY'RE TRYING TO GET THE POLICE
TO COME IN.
THEY EVEN OFFER TO UNLOCK THE
DOOR.
>> THE KIDS OFFERED TO UNLOCK
THE DOOR.
I MEAN -- THE FOURTH GRADERS
HAVE MORE COURAGE, OR MORE
INTELLIGENCE THAN SOME OF THE
FOLKS IN THE HALLWAY.
IT'S STUNNING TO ME.
I SHOULD SAY THE LEADERSHIP.
BECAUSE THERE'S PLENTY OF LOW
LEVEL POLICE OFFICERS WHO WANT
TO GO IN.
WHO WANT TO DO THE RIGHT THING.
THEY DON'T WANT TO BE
INCOMPETENT WILL BUT THEY'RE
CRYING OUT FOR SOME FREAKING
LEADERSHIP.
>> YOU CAN SEE IN THE BODY CAM.
THEY'RE TELLING THE OFFICERS
THERE, THERE ARE KIDS IN THE
CLASSROOM.
GO IN, GO IN.
AND EVERYONE JUST FREEZES AND NO
ONE DOES A THING.
THAT CALL IS 20 MINUTES OF JUST
BRUTAL HELL FOR THESE KIDS.
TO HEAR THEM.
THERE IS SO MUCH THAT WE DON'T
SHOW.
SO MUCH WE DON'T PLAY BECAUSE IT
IS SO BRUTAL.
BUT IT WAS IMPORTANT TO SHOW, TO
SHOW VIEWERS EXACTLY THE MOMENTS
INSIDE THERE AND HOW HORRIFIC IT
WAS.
MEANWHILE, POLICE OFFICERS WERE
STANDING JUST FEET AWAY FROM THE
DOOR.
THE OTHER THING IS THE GUNMAN.
HE WAS DISTRACTED.
THEY HAD PLENTY OF OPPORTUNITY.
HAD THEY MADE A BETTER EFFORT TO
FIGURE OUT WHAT WAS GOING ON
INSIDE, THERE WERE TWO ROOMS.
AT ONE POINT HE WAS IN ANOTHER
ROOM.
>> THERE WERE HUNDREDS OF
OFFICERS.
>> THE KIDS WEREN'T EVEN SURE IF
HE WAS STILL IN THE ROOM.
COULD YOU HEAR THE LOUD MUSIC
BECAUSE HE WAS PLAYING IT SO
LOUD.
>> HE WAS PLAYING MUSIC.
AND YOU COULD HEAR IT.
THERE WAS PLENTY OF TIME FOR
THEM TO GO INSIDE.
THAT'S WHAT THIS AUDIO TAPE
CLEARLY MAKES.
AND WHY THEY DID IT, WHAT THEY
WERE DOING DURING THOSE MOMENTS.
THERE'S MORE REPORTING TO COME.
WE'RE STILL DIGG